et pour parler de cette visite du
président égyptien à paris nous sommes
avec emmanuel dupuy président de l'ipl
institut prospective et c'est que était
en europe
emmanuel dupuis bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
lutte contre le terrorisme la libye le
conflit israélo palestinien ou encore la
crise politique au liban les sujets de
discussion ne vont pas manquer entre
emmanuel macron est elle si si est-ce
que l'egypte représente un pôle de
stabilité aujourd'hui dans une région
qui est troublé par les crises
le président hu man match on a trois
formules pour mentionner la raison pour
laquelle l'egypte est importante pour la
france c'est qu'un partenaire
stratégique vous l'avez mentionné qu'en
ce qui concerne la lutte contre le
terrorisme
quand le président al sisi était
président en exercice de l'union
africaine il avait de manière plus que
symbolique soutenu l'action française
dans sa lutte contre les groupes armés
terroristes en soutenant évidemment les
nombreuses initiatives pour y parvenir
au sahel
c'est également un allié incontournable
comme vous l'avez mentionné avec son
million d'habitants l'egypte est le pays
arabe le plus peuplé c'est un immense
marché
vous avez mentionné les 24 afin que nous
avons déjà vendu en 2015 des quatre
corvettes que nous avons vendus en 2014
et potentiellement les douze nous rafale
que l'egypte aurait dû racheter
évidemment il n'y a pas que la question
de la défense
le métro du caire avec à sa tête un
contrat que la france a remporté il ya
peu de temps
mais évidemment il faut aussi avoir à
l'esprit que la relation est un petit
peu hypertrophié entre la france et
l'egypte entre 2013 et 2017 la france a
été le premier fournisseur militaire
ce que d'ailleurs dénonce beaucoup
d'organisations humanitaires et des
droits de l'homme mais au-delà de cette
strate de ce caractère de partenaires
stratégiques et de satin lien
contournable il ya aussi la dimension
effectivement des problèmes
enfin ou des discussions vous avez
mentionné le fait que l'internet visite
du président mm macro l'egypte en
janvier 2019 suivi de la dernière
rencontre qui s'est déroulée à
l'occasion du g7 de biarritz à l'époque
où le président et ceux ci était
président d'une africaine
et l'idée ces questions la question va
revenir
évidemment sur la table puisque vous
avez mentionné le fait qu' il y a
actuellement une mobilisation très forte
de la part de ces organisations
humanitaires alors que lors d'une
dernière rencontre en présence de
l'ambassadeur france je crois que c'est
important de le contextualiser ainsi un
certain nombre de militants des droits
de l'homme se sont fait arrêter quelques
heures après avoir rencontré les envois
de plusieurs ambassadeurs occidentaux à
paris dont le cas emblématique depuis
120 501 jours donc de samy sa mère a
lancé mme chirac mais qui est qui est
actuellement toujours embastillé
nonobstant le geste de bonne volonté que
vous annoncez que vous avez mentionné
trois représentants de l'association des
jeunes pour les droits personnels ont
été libérés quelques heures avant la
visite du président ici mais évidemment
les organisations des droits de l'homme
mentionne le fait qu'il reste encore
soixante mille détenus pour délit
d'opinion en egypte et justement la
question des droits de l'homme
on sait très bien que c'est une question
qui fait grincer des dents
vous avez mentionné justement ces
rencontres entre le 6 et emmanuel macron
en 2010 est déjà emmanuel macron avait
été interrogé sur la question des droits
de l'homme il avait à ce moment-là
déclaré qu'il n'avait pas de leçon à
donner
en 2019 il avait regretté que la
situation n'évolue pas dans le dans la
bonne direction
des facteurs et si c'est d'ailleurs avec
lui mise en avant d'abord quand on parle
de droits humains le droit des égyptiens
à vivre dans la dignité
après des années de présidence moubarak
le président el sissi avait mentionné le
fait que la question des droits nommé
consul essentielle de la situation
sécuritaire dans son pays il en
rappelant évidemment que il y à de
nombreux attentats qui endeuillent au
quotidien les populations égyptiennes
mais je crois qu'il est important de
rappeler également que cette question
des droits de l'homme ne concerne pas
que l'egypte elle concerne la manière
dont l'egypte est impliqué ou on
soutient un certain nombre de régimes
qui peut sont interrogés et je pense
notamment au conflit au yémen conflit en
libye voulait elle mentionné ou au fait
en syrie où
la position française à qu être
divergentes
durant de nombreuses années mais qui
semble effectivement être convergentes
c'est particulièrement vrai sur la
question libyenne aujourd'hui c'est un
petit peu moins vrai sur la question
qatari on se souvient d'ailleurs que le
l'egypte a soutenu bahreïn les émirats
arabes unis et l'arabie saoudite
dans sa volonté de marginaliser le qatar
depuis la crise de janvier 2017 ce sujet
sera aussi sur la table des négociations
après la visite de mindoubé ou dans
plusieurs pays du golfe persique
notamment au qatar et il y à quelques
heures encore de jared kushner qui tente
dans le cadre de la dernière ligne
droite de la présidence trempe d'essayer
de de régulation chose que la france
n'avait pas pu faire puisqu'elle s'était
elle même proposé comme médiatrice à
l'aune de cette crise entre le quartier
d'un côté et laudateurs de bouc l'egypte
qui joue également le rôle de rempart
contre l'islamisme politique au
moyen-orient
el sissi a plusieurs fois dénoncé
justement les les actes de terrorisme de
la part des frères musulmans
aujourd'hui c'est emmanuel macron qui
s'en prend également aux frères
musulmans
après les attentats terroristes comme on
a pu voir ces derniers mois en france
oui mais là il ya un paradoxe la récente
visite du mit les affaires étrangères
jean yves le drian au caire le 7 et le 8
novembre s'est pas du tout passé comme
il l'espérait puisque la rencontre qu'il
a eue avec l'autorité morale la plus
haute autorité morale et intellectuelle
hasard du monde arabe
suite le doyen le grand imam de
l'université al azhar ahmad al tayeb ne
s'est pas du tout passé comme le
souhaitait le le le le grand imam qui
d'ailleurs dans la constitution
égyptienne à un niveau protocolaire
équivalent à celui du premier ministre
avait dans les heures qui ont suivi de
la visite vertement critiqué la position
française est absolument pas adoubé la
position que la france espérait de sa
part de plus grande tolérance par
rapport à la position française
donc je crois que c'est une question qui
n'est pas réglé et là aussi il ya un
paradoxe la france s'attaque évidemment
un certain nombre d'organisations que
considèrent comme terroriste l'egypte
mais ça ne veut pas dire que l'egypte et
la france ont la même vision ou le même
regard sur la question de l'islam et
notamment la question de l'islam en noir
merci beaucoup emmanuel dupuis d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président de l'ups l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe